[Música]
la ciudad ecuatoriana de Guayaquil está
en estado de emergencia luego de la
explosión del domingo que mató a cinco
personas y dejó 17 heridos el puerto de
esta urbe se ha convertido en un lugar
central del envío de cocaína Tenemos
reporte desde Ecuador
la economía de Brasil creció en un 2,24%
el primer semestre del año en
comparación con el mismo periodo del
2021 aunque los expertos apuntan que
para el resto del 2022 podría haber una
desaceleración ampliamos con nuestro
periodista especializado en el tema
los efectos prolongados de la sequía en
California han llevado a las autoridades
a diseñar planes para crear más
depósitos de agua también la esperanza
aparece estar en el océano Pacífico de
donde podrían extraer agua y
desalinizarla
Bienvenidos a Franz 24 Estas son las
noticias dedicadas al continente
americano los saluda a María Clara calle
en estado de emergencia amaneció el
lunes la ciudad ecuatoriana de Guayaquil
así lo decretó el gobierno de Guillermo
lasso tras la explosión del domingo que
dejó cinco muertos y 17 heridos las
autoridades lo catalogan como un acto
terrorista leve y lo atribuyen a
enfrentamientos entre las bandas que se
disputan las rutas del narcotráfico
nuestro corresponsal en Quito Gustavo
Ortega nos explicó qué pasa en Guayaquil
donde se han registrado la mitad de los
ataques con explosivos que ha habido en
el país este año específicamente son 72
los atentados de tipo terrorista que han
sucedido en la ciudad de Guayaquil tal y
como tú hacías hace referencia a la
mitad de los eventos de materia con
explosivo y específicamente El Ejecutivo
en nacional ha sido cuestionado
específicamente hay que tomar en cuenta
que los niveles de muertes violencias
también se incrementado en el último año
hay que conocer que por lo menos en el
año 2017 se produjeron 126 muertes
violentas y en el año 2022 se lo que va
diario se han producido un poco más de
861 muertes violentas Lo cierto es que
analistas comparan esto lo sucedido que
El Ejecutivo en nacional en Guayaquil y
demandan acciones rápidas Por lo cual
considera que si no podría producirse lo
sucedido en Bogotá en la década de los
80 con el Cartel de Medellín la
principal economía de latinoamérica la
de Brasil creció en el primer semestre
de este año la novedad Es que este
aumento se da a pesar de que la
inflación interanual es de dos dígitos
para esta nación para hablar de esto nos
acompaña en estudio nuestro periodista
Juan Pablo lucumín Juan Pablo bienvenido
y explíquenos De cuánto fue este
incremento
Pues sí María Clara Brasil acumuló un
alza del 2,24% en los primeros seis
meses de este año según el Banco Central
de ese país luego de haber sufrido las
consecuencias de la pandemia en este
mismo periodo del año pasado la
principal economía de latinoamérica pasa
por una fase de recuperación a un ritmo
de crecimiento interanual del 2,18%
según el índice de actividad económica
Esta es una medición previa del producto
interno bruto el gobierno brasileño
asegura que espera una expansión del pib
del 2% para este año pero el fondo
monetario internacional estima una
expansión de 3 puntos porcentuales menos
o el
1,7%. los datos muestran cierta
resiliencia de la economía brasileña
Pero según los expertos para este
segundo semestre del año se prevé una
desaceleración esto por la presión que
pone los precios de la guerra de en
Ucrania y nuevo y los nuevos
confinamientos del covid 19 en China
sumado a todo en los próximos meses el
país celebrará elecciones generales en
los últimos 12 meses del año Brasil
acumuló el 10,07% de la inflación uno de
los datos más altos de América Latina
Juan Pablo gracias por su reporte y
nosotros cambiamos de noticias porque el
lunes comenzaron en Venezuela los juegos
militares que organiza Rusia Es la
primera vez que este país
latinoamericano acoge a los llamados
army games desde 2015 el año en el que
empezó a ser partícipe de las justas
además de los rusos y los venezolanos
participan países a los que el kremlin
considera como aliados entre ellos están
belarús Nicaragua china e India
previamente el contrabalmirante Carlos
Molina ex consejero de seguridad y
defensa de Venezuela nos preciso si los
juegos se pueden considerar como una
provocación de Rusia en medio de las
tensiones con occidente por la guerra en
Ucrania
Sí evidentemente y lo ha dicho
públicamente de Putin él quiere cambiar
el mundo y hacerlo multipolar Pero
además de eso ahí hay otras
maniobras ocultas y ya una la de hoy que
es la la venta masiva de armas
Eso es parte de de las esta intenciones
que tiene que venir pero evidentemente
que él quiere penetrar el continente
iberoamericano
y hacer de aliados de todos estos países
Especialmente los países donde está
gobernando la izquierda la extrema
izquierda el contralmirante Molina
también nos habló de una nueva disputa
de entre Rusia y Estados Unidos en
América Latina
desde que cayó el muro Berlín de que se
acabó la guerra fría por supuesto Rusia
se ha se ha venido mermando tanto como
sistemas de armas como de geografía
porque muchos países aliados se les han
pasado a la otan pero evidentemente que
es es tratar de de pisar el patio de los
aliados tradicionales Estados Unidos en
el continente americano
vamos a Estados Unidos California Busca
mitigar los efectos de la prolongada
sequía que sea intensificado por la
crisis climática el cálculo es que el
estado pierda para el 2040 el 10% del
suministro de agua que tiene actualmente
lo que ha llevado a las autoridades a
crear más depósitos de reservas
acuíferas y también a poner en marcha
plantas para potabilizar parte del agua
del océano Pacífico veamos la historia
de Andrés granadillo
una estrategia para mitigar la sequía el
gobernador de California Busca
solucionar los graves problemas de agua
que sufre el estado en los últimos años
la hidrología en el estado ha comenzado
a cambiar de forma bastante
significativa la aridificación que
estamos experimentando nos lleva la
ciencia y los datos nos llevan a
entender ahora que perderemos el 10% de
nuestro suministro de agua para 2040
para reducir esta cifra anunció que la
planta desalinizadora que se está
construyendo en Antioch una población a
72 kilómetros de San Francisco
convertirá el agua salobre en agua
potable además el plan prevé la creación
de un almacenamiento de casi 5.000
millones de metros cúbicos de agua el
reciclaje o reutilización del líquido y
proyectos de captación de aguas
pluviales
y la realidad es que tenemos que ser más
creativos y tenemos que ser más
agresivos en términos no solo de
promover esta tecnología sino de cumplir
con su promesa es más cumplir con su
potencial el estado reservó más de 8.000
millones de dólares en los últimos tres
años para modernizarlas infraestructuras
hídricas que generarán agua suficiente
para 8,4 millones de hogares en un
estado de 40 millones de habitantes la
crisis del agua se ha visto agravada por
el cambio climático California y el
oeste del país han experimentado una
sequía extrema los últimos 20 años
algunos científicos han medido este
periodo como el más seco en 1.200 años
este fenómeno ha ocasionado fuertes
incendios como el de makini que dejó más
de 22.000 hectáreas de bosque calcinado
y cientos de afectados
en México colectivos de mujeres y
familiares de Marisela López protestaron
frente al palacio de Justicia pidiendo
su Liberación ella fue condenada a 25
años de cárcel por haber matado en 2019
a su marido antes de que este la atacara
la abogada alega que si su defendida no
reaccionaba los muertos habrían sido
ella sus dos hijos y el bebé que llevaba
en el vientre informa lluis Muñoz
familiares y colectivos de indígenas
pidieron este lunes la liberación de
Maricela López Bautista se trata de una
mujer indígena tzotzil que el 20 de
noviembre de 2019 mató a su marido este
estaba afilando su machete borracho y
drogado y ella respondió con un leño la
de los hechos es que Marisela ese día lo
que hizo fue defender su vida la vida
del bebé que llevaba en el vientre
porque ella estaba embarazada de seis
meses y la vida de sus otros dos
chiquititos menores de edad el 19 de
abril un juzgado de San Cristóbal de las
Casas en el Sureño estado de Chiapas la
condenó a 25 años de prisión los
manifestantes denuncian que no se
tuvieron en cuenta las pruebas que
evidenciaban la continua violencia que
recibía también argumentan que no tuvo
un juicio justo en este sentido el caso
de es uno de los tantos casos que
existen México de mujeres de hombres que
no han tenido la oportunidad de tener un
intérprete con perspectiva de género con
mirada intercultural México vive una
crisis de violencia machista según la
ONU cada día son asesinadas 10 mujeres
mientras según organizaciones hay una
impunidad entre el 97 y el 99% de los
casos en el gobierno de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador los feminicidios se han
disparado este ha culpado al
neoliberalismo pero los colectivos
feministas acusan a los recortes en
programas contra la violencia machista
así llegamos al final de este
informativo ustedes sigan en transmite 4
[Música]